so on the wedding day real quick I need  to get a haircut to the wedding planner  she's like yep I got someone great it is  some dude and a woman and they just  their presentation was like they were  traveling they didn't seem like Barbers  at all okay he turns to the girl and he  goes  go ahead she takes the Clippers fires  them on  two hands oh no she goes look down I'm  like oh God and I'm thinking you brought  your assistant yeah he's like it's our  first time yeah dude I'm teaching her  oh the day of your wedding yes she could  take a chunk out of your head I'm sorry  she's still learning yeah she's like  kind of cutting that she pulls off and  keeps like checking the Clipper and I'm  like  some of your skin yeah